we're gonna hand over to these these
lovely people that have asked questions
first up surgeon is Michael Carlton
whilst we're getting the mic to Mike
Michael Charlton forgive me Michael
whilst we're doing that as well I just
want to give it I want to give an
exceptional thank outside spec shout out
to IBM Laura Dave who covered a pound
for every single pound this is things
brought right-hook behavioral marketing
there are 10 copies to buy here today
very happy to give all the money to
charity but please pick one I'll buy
yeah okay done thank you
first question for our friend Michael is
the camera on our pillow so we can get
some shine is that we've got the one the
official cameras on our friend you don't
like cameras dude you're such a good
looking dude you did not or you did I
did it
and now when you're discussing about
young people being entrepreneurs yes
like the space that I work in is with
people at University and I've always
gotten a point where the work from like
two years and you know help them improve
them and then leave set up their own
rival company and go lucky and it goes
me every time yeah I can't get past a
point and it's I know we're talking
you're gonna fail like you don't know
how how this is and they obviously go
off and try it and fail but some have
one no that means the first one but
everything after that has failed because
the first one left you got pissed you're
not teaching them as well I know this
game yeah yes conscious it's like the
Portuguese will do better you know that
conscious unless then that's got less
barriers to entry like it in in a market
if you're training somebody open it and
they can leave like when you just stop
yeah that's a great question you know
I'm a bad person to ask because I've
done something so weird I but I've made
it so obvious to my employees do you
know any employees have told me they
entire plan big shout out Gabe was to
come to be
steal my [ __ ] and go do their [ __ ] and
this is not a zing on you what I'm doing
is it I'm making it so obvious that
being number 400 with me will make them
more happiness and money than being
number one with them that they come in
and then they change what I think you
need to think about is what can you do
to replicate that feeling if that's what
you want to do or or you start building
up C players instead of B players that's
right it's gonna work
if that's your model those are two
options either either input it like it's
yeah like like it's either building up
its either becoming a super a plus
yourself or playing with C players
because bees are gonna be vulnerable in
the way that you described cool thank
you you're welcome thank you very much I
love real talk
how can love real talk guys start
demanding more real talk in these
business [ __ ] flexures I shall see
you there Michael one of the biggest
proponents of vaina world certainly on
social media and especially on Twitter
next question over to Vikki funk yeah
yeah I know her right here look at the
t-shirt stand up as well so we can get
you on camera lightless let's clap it up
she's a lovely lady
[Applause]
yes all right
freestyle Facebook and Instagram yes
okay we seem to build this one minute
everybody loves us Facebook features
success story it tells us that we do
really well and then 48 hours will go by
and then nothing putting you adverts out
it's very very nice
you mean the feed organically I'm trying
to figure out help me understand why
you're asking themselves well maybe
because that different audience wasn't
the right move what are you trying to
make happen with the content get social
engagement or create a transaction
transaction okay
well listen I can tell you from a lot of
data there's enormous amounts of
transactional stuff going on in the UK
so I don't you know are you saying that
the first thing the first thing you did
was that going to your organic audience
or is it all advertising
how many coat like when you so you did
something and it worked
yeah and then you try to do a look-alike
or other segmentation yeah
there's so many different reasons that
might not be working it would probably
take up the rest of the night there's a
couple questions first the depth and the
quality of your product is the number
one variable some products can sell to
everybody in the world Apple and some
can sell to six and so that would be the
first thing I would look at if we were
hanging out for six hours
I like how good is your thing really
right and is the best segmentation you
know like I
we say like there's some businesses that
have very small cohorts that will
convert and the second you go outside of
it nothing you can do will work because
what you're selling is not gonna sell
that's my first intuition but there's a
million other things but there's
definitely nothing different in the UK
or the u.s. behavior in Big Data that
makes me think that's the case there
could you know yeah it said I mean I
just don't see it Instagram ads are
acting clunky still like they're not
there yet the the data is not mapping to
the cohort I just ran a piece of content
against 18 25 year-old african-american
males and the comments have like 60
year-old white chicks in there like what
the [ __ ] you know so it's not working
yet but it's going it's got the
potential to be a great product thank
you so much the product like is the
really the thing you have to look
because that's very unusual and the
times I've seen it it's been more about
the depth of the product than any other
variable marketing thing those t-shirts
snapchat bags it's like snapchat stuff
so what's the flick you know I mean I
would I first of all if they're trying
to sell snapchat stuff I much recommend
more for you to pay snapchat influencers
to do product placement than anything
else that's I mean like but the problem
is there's no way to build snapchat swag
as a business because there's 900 people
that are doing it there's no point of
differentiation you'll be completely
commoditized you're writing a quick wave
you're making a quick buck you're not
building a business you're building
snapchats business you know next up is
and I'm gonna reading this off for a
handwriting Glen Eliot is that right
surgeon where is Ben Elliot Glen Elliot
stand up thank you for buying 50 books
mate appreciate Glen thank you for
buying 50 books and a very handsome
question right now what song
though their great culture danuel
company what is my advice for building
great content in your company great
culture culture yeah um I've got a lot
on this and and honestly this is
probably the place where I can see
myself going more and more because soon
veiners really really really gonna be
big and it's gonna be really because of
this and then I'll feel confident that
I'm allowed to talk about it I've
started talking about a little bit
because we're starting to get big first
and foremost
are you are you the partner CEOs like is
it your business yeah
first and foremost you have to realize
in a real way in a non [ __ ] way that
you work for them if you do not do that
you've lost if you think people work for
you as the CEO or the founder of a
company versus you working for them you
will never ever ever ever ever ever have
Suman ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever build a good culture in a company
that's number one that is religious that
is number one got it
number two you have to realize that
there is no blanket rules everybody in
your company how many boys yes
330 great nice number you have to
micromanage 330 people's wants ambitions
and needs on an everyday basis
predicates on what else is happening
their lives
day after day month after month year
after year so what that means is he may
be both motivated by money I love when
people like millenials are so Zen and
that I only Millennials who literally
rather work an extra 20 hours for six
more bucks they love money and you know
so like you have to figure out what
drives them is it money is it work-life
balance is it like are they a huge you
know Chelsea fan and you buy them random
tickets when they aren't looking and
then they're like oh my god you actually
know something about me right you think
I pay attention a lot to you guys I
[ __ ] stop the [ __ ] out of my 650
employees on social media
I know who [ __ ] loves tinder I know
who loves bourbon I know it all and so
it's very hard to scale one on one
context with 330 employees the other
thing is you have to build
infrastructure last Friday I announced a
new role that I announced was the most
senior role in the company besides me
more senior than AJ more senior than
James Orsini I right-hand guy more
senior than my CFO who was Claude sober
who is now my partner basically in the
company and she's the chief heart
officer she will help me scale the
mapping of one to one at scale because
you know Rick who wants money at 22 to
24 to 27 might want something else when
he gets engaged because his partner
wants him home on the weekends and used
to want to work and make money and so he
would work on Saturday and now he
doesn't want to or scary or [ __ ] that
I'm always mentally prepared for which
is a tragedy may happen in your family
and you have to leave for nine months
and you come back shaken and so you've
got it the only way to build great
culture is not only through words that
are written on the wall but in your
actions you have to make every one of
those people understand that you care
more about them than you want them to
care about you
it is only I swear I'm trying to do it
at a level that's never been done before
but wherever I land is what I will have
if I'm a 92 in the markets a sixty-seven
that's incredible right you can't be
crippled by the task what I just said
some people get crippled when I tell
them that advice on 13 employees you got
3:30 my man I got 650 like it's tough
but if you do it you will build great
culture and if you don't every step of
the way that you do less of it you will
have less of that culture
[Applause]
and and it's about allocating dollars to
the right things one of the best things
I do is the most talented people my
company if they are not bought into
being the bigger woman and bigger man in
every situation I don't care if their
number-one salesperson the best creative
director they're [ __ ] fired right and
you have to be religious about that the
second you let somebody get away with
something you will lose and then
meritocracy we started the company with
a debate Jay's friends some of them are
the number 10 most important and well
compensate employee and some of them are
number 387 meritocracy right if you take
care of your nephew better than
somebody's hustling you've died you're
done your cultures broke you let
something besides meritocracy rule
fantastic Belarus the last place that
lets meritocracy for the last place the
last dictatorship in Europe whew next up
is a Adrian Savage thank you for buying
50 books Adrian please put your hand up
or stand up here he is over there how
are you Phoenix is our spot bro see you
in four years yeah definitely but you
really hit me in the heart last time in
a way they didn't before okay really
think about contents the first time yes
but the thing hit me with was you said
that that audience was a naught was an
audience of trans actors yes and they
are my audience they and my business
they my customers yes so how quickly are
they likely to change how much do I need
to change to accommodate that and my now
suddenly seen the lights I'm thinking
about contents the first time what else
should I be doing differently so you
well I appreciate you saying hold on to
the mic I think that um that was an
interesting talk because just to give
you guys context digital marketing a lot
of people are in are in performance
marketing and they think that they're in
marketing but really performances sales
they're in performance sales right you
caught a good long you know long term
goo
that's converting you found an arbitrage
on a cohort on a Facebook ad right it's
transactional and and I'm glad you
caught that I felt really good about
that talk because you know as well as I
do that was an interesting talk right
like I came in and ninety-eight percent
of the audience was doing one thing and
I told him that was rubbish and I told
him more importantly that that what
thing was not only rubbish that it was
in deep danger over the next three to
four years which is true because a lot
of people as you know as I know in that
room transact in a desktop internet
world this [ __ ] right here my man
she doesn't extinct like this is like
[ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ] is
this right like this is over and so the
reason I went at it is this is over
because this is here yeah and the fact
that I now business travel with only my
phone and do all my work on it it's
crazy I don't know how my laptop bag
anymore it's so weird and so you're
landing your your your email capture
pop-up on desktop is kind of [ __ ] up
but acceptable because at least there's
other real estate on this [ __ ] thing
not as good right and all your behaviors
so how long I don't know but my
intuition is a lot of people are quite
vulnerable because arbitrage and your
move and your Commission Junction move
that worked died your google adword
thing died so like a lot of those people
get fleshed out for you when I hear
they're your customers I like that
because I said to myself okay if he's
Cena like what you need to do is you
need to become a media company you need
to put out great content and not about
what you do let's say you do tax SAS
let's see what you did is you founded
I'm sure that's not it but let's say
that you sell software that helps people
that are digital marketers do taxes what
you need to do is help put out content
not about taxes but about running a
business right about you know managing
your will like the other things that
that person cares about got it so you
need to think about your content
directly with what you do
but more broadly so you become a value
to them and then you have leverage and
that's what I try to do with my
concentrate try to talk about a lot of
things I've really opened it up with
this emotional intelligence because it's
an equal part of running a business and
that's me broadening and bringing value
so I would tell you in podcast form
writing on medium.com in video form
snapchat form whatever is most
comfortable to you to communicate to the
world you need to become a media company
as a matter of fact every single person
in this room needs to become a media
company , you sell [ __ ]
wine Brit business back there big shout
out wine brand be a media company first
comma then sell wine if you're educating
people about wine culture and about
cheese and about travel you then build
equity to be able to transact on your
wine but nobody's thinking that way
they're thinking so narrow and so
transactional and what happens with
transactions is when there's a shift in
platform they died because they didn't
build a brand and they don't translate I
jump back on snapchat there's 20,000
people ready for me to go that's brand
every platform I sign up for if I'm a
little bit like if I want to not do it
right away there's a queue of people
ready to hear for me people squat you
Gary Vee now on every social network
that pops up and then send me an email
like Gary Vee I took your name if you
give me an hour I'll give it to you I'm
like [ __ ] you I'm gonna get it you know
so you know anyway brand brands from
Nike didn't tag Nike didn't cookie my
browser and follow me around the
internet and make me eventually buy
Nikes I buy Nikes because they branded
me I'm sorry how's it feel it feels good
yeah did I did anything interesting
happens sometimes it takes six months
but than anything anything weird
happened that like you're like oh [ __ ] I
saw you realize I could do it and there
was something was actually holding me
back
and then some dude stood onstage and
punched in the mouth and you did it and
you know what that feedback does it
helps you strategize one of the selfish
things with the askgaryvee stuff is I'm
learning what people are thinking
predicated on what they're asking
it's a scaled version of listening thank
you you're welcome
next up is Wesley Frank eyebrows that
right Frank Wesley put your hands up man
let's get the mic over to him
Gary hi how are you I'm very well in
support West Ham United does is everyone
knows have you won a championship in 25
years
[ __ ] yeah I'm interested get me more
data got me into your content yes and I
followed you avidly since then you
talked a little while ago about the 19
year old entrepreneur yes the biggest
asset is patience yes what is the
preneur what should they have was there
as a fix on the patient three years ago
I started a business with some other
some other guys we're now 80 people
turning over 10 million pounds amazing
one more absolutely fantastic
this is amazing what's my biggest asset
now well I think your asset is
experience all the cliche stuff it's
just cliche it's you know everybody said
it what I think though is do I think
instead of saying experience I'm gonna
tweak it a little bit do I think a 46
year old man has a better chance of
knowing himself than a 19 year old man
yes I do I think we've all gone through
it right even think about your
transition from high school to
universally you just get there right you
get more comfortable with yourself ii
get more comfortable with yourself you
start being more honest with yourself to
do that so at this point in your life
and my life and you're like we should
really know ourselves and so what when I
hear it's an even interesting for me to
hear that you started with a couple
other gentlemen to me my hope for my own
kind of like personal picture that I'm
trying to pay
here is that the three of you had some
crossover skills but you're all
maintaining your core skill and that's
what's helping the business right you're
taking care of this that person wait
Steve you take care of that and the
other person's there that's a very
common thing for older entrepreneurs
because at that point they've shed their
wants and their romance about being the
best sales guy or the best sales girl
and now they know I'm really good at CFO
finances I'll never let us go out of
business I've got the numbers don't
worry guys you go be crazy cuz I'm gonna
make sure we pay our bills you go make
sure the staff loves us and now we've
got this I was gifted that I do a lot of
the principles well all of them finance
probably being my weakest it's probably
the one that's most commoditized
and when you're in business with your
dad and your brother if they steal from
you it's a good story right so so I
think that um I think that your biggest
advantage is that you got it's probably
the narrative to why you were succeeding
now the question becomes a more
interesting one I'm gonna take you in a
different place that's probably more
grounded in the actual like energy I
think the big thing now at this point in
your life is to really try to figure out
very quickly what you want to happen and
the problem is you have two other people
that may want different things but if
you're able to alignment that you guys
want to sell the company soon because
that's a real cash out on that kind of
revenue then all of your behaviors have
to go in that direction you have to
figure out who you can sell to you have
to start becoming a media company to
them one of the great misplays of brand
is if I wanted to sell vaynermedia
tomorrow it would happen in 30 minutes
not on revenue on the fact that I would
market to the people that could actually
buy me
I don't think Martin Sorrell knows who I
am in 20 minutes he would want to rip
his arm off to buy us that's what I'm
good at so what I would love to know is
how aligned are you guys and if you're
aligned make all your actions go in that
direction that's interesting to me right
that's where you can really make
something amazing happen so I think
that's something to really give some
serious thought to but I think it's it's
self awareness at this point you could
you could you've got so much more
history in your 20 30 years of
entrepreneurship that allows you to and
and you should shed even whatever
whatever pride you have left in
principle
that you don't bring to the table as
well as you know partner sue the more
you can shut down to only focusing on
what you do mean AJ are so efficient
because we do not discuss the things
that we know the other person is better
at we don't even talk about it
you know big and when one broaches the
subject the other gets pissed right
because like why would we even waste
time you know I'm better at this than
you and we've become efficient like
[ __ ] [ __ ] efficient you know and
time is the asset so why'd it be got it
yeah that's great yeah and the other
thing I'll tell you I would highly
recommend you forcing your other two
partners to over communicate with the
three of you at all time like force
communication right now you're
successful and you're at this age this
is an interesting time like force
communication anything that you think is
sitting in your heart that needs to be
talked about with your other two
partners I would tell you do that
tomorrow
the quicker you get it out the better
you're gonna be
the final 50 book purchase question is
going out to a job and by the name of
Luke Johnson please stand up Luke family
shredded by science where that online
education providing for personal
trainers okay I know Mike's done a
superb job against reddit
yes good job Mike skip my cravat yeah so
in regards to you said you can you know
where it's gonna go in the next 10 to 15
years where'd you see the fitness
industry which at the moment is a the
online coaching and if one wants to be
an online coach and is passive income
where we know it's not passive income
where do you see maybe VR or the fitness
industry going some no you've mentioned
about entrepreneur me entrepreneur
tenants right now um so I don't think I
know where things are going 10 to 15
years I think I have intuitions and I
think what I'm really good at is moving
fast when I see it that's number one
look I mean Fitness is gonna only
continue to grow people you know any
meditation I think is one of the great
open spaces I so I think the amount of
money being that's gonna be made in
meditation is gonna be enormous just
enormous I think meditation is no
question the next eating healthy you
know and and working out right mental
health is going to become a much bigger
conversation and meditation is at the
forefront and so I think that's one
thing that's very clear to me as far as
physical and things of that nature
look I mean it's never gonna go away and
you know it's gonna only grow supply and
demand is gonna happen it's not a it's
very low cost of entry to get into the
game
you know I I'd like to think that the
market reads itself out from people that
are you know I look at Fitness very
similar to the way I look at
entrepreneurship there's a ton of
hucksters their entire marketing
strategy is taking cute selfies to put
on Instagram which is fine
and quite enjoyable in a lot of ways but
yeah I mean ya know I mean look cuz
dudes are scum buckets so that's why you
know I think that um I think that I'd
like to think that the people that
deserve to win are gonna win because
they continue to try to refine their
craft and add nutrition into their game
educate themselves you know but passive
income when you're online coaching
you're not gonna keep anybody as an
online coach if you try to make it
passive because you're not gonna be
giving them anything
Mike's stopping taking clients he
doesn't want any more like he's at the
prime of his game and he doesn't want to
hire people underneath him to scale and
he's stretched he's stretched he doesn't
like so it only scales so much if you do
it right or you can trick the tool for a
few minutes and you get top-line revenue
but then you have no lifetime value and
they go away and so what you just keep
gonna go to the bottom and trick people
and not feel good about yourself and
make money in a [ __ ] way cool fine I
actually fundamentally predict that it's
gonna look a lot the same we're just
gonna be doing it in different places
sure well do VR and then people are
gonna look good in real life versus
looking good on Instagram I mean like
it's a it's a it's a some people play on
vanity and I'd like to think that it
will go through a cleansing where people
get exposed for not providing the right
value some people are just genetically
inclined and are in great shape to begin
with and then they just ARB what mom and
dad gave them to the marketplace and
that sucks but like whatever I mean I
don't know I think I think it looks
pretty much the same really I do
you want a good
provided me in my business yes or see my
team I'd love maybe to come with the
team and do make nutrition training
thing oh you got to talk to Mike he's in
charge
um Mike's the CEO I'd charm him
fantastic thank you
you mean me like a book anybody what did
that man did that extra banana feet
Gary's macros good he lets me he like
it's like it's okay when I cheat with
fruit thanks Mike you're real [ __ ]
sport
so Jim I'll run it to the back I was
gonna say go to the back too somehow
somebody who's been kind enough to stand
up for whatever reason went out to the
back general entry tickets general entry
tickets make some noise ooh this guy
just snitched on himself he's got a
general entry trick itself in the
premium section you're real hi Deena no
[ __ ]
I didn't actually know who you were
before I came in today by the way no
[ __ ] that's always way better than
the reverse I love it go ahead Lee came
with my friends but I'm glad I did I
really really glad I did thank you
I guess it's a bit deep for me but I'm I
guess I feel like I've grown up in a box
I was told to go to university
yep get a degree yep get married yep
have a house and have children I
understand and I Brown so that was the
kind of way are not dictated it wasn't
recommended and it's like you I grew up
I am did a paper round I wish cars I
clean houses I irons and now get around
my full-time job I was a lawyer
and now I'm an entrepreneur yes
Bollywood borrowed and we rent out
engine clothing now when I find
difficult sometimes it's how many
Brazilians the the patience and the kind
of drive and ambition to keep going to
strive even when you get knocked down
and even when I'm put up against all
this pressure for my my parents my
friends to get a job you know have a
stable job have a stable income it's
just about keeping going
unless something so what I'm wondering
is what keeps you what kept you
motivated what kept you going
what kept you inspired so it's
interesting when you were talking you're
like now I'm an entrepreneur and I was
laughing I'm like you've always been an
entrepreneur you got forced to do the
other thing no little girl is running
around and doing a paper route that's
not an entrepreneur do you know what I
mean
you know what kept me going is I would
suffocate if I did anything else and I
have a funny feeling you would too so
you're more than welcome to not breathe
as easy and go that route or do you
that's on you you know like I'll listen
hit me up on [ __ ] every social
network I'll tell you every day go do
your thing go go I'm thrilled I love
being a cheerleader I feel like I got so
gifted by having a cheerleader in my
mother that I almost feel guilty how
good I had it that I want to give it to
you that's why that's why I love
interacting with so many of you I'm I
don't like the motivational part of me
because I don't want to go down that
guru path but I'm thrilled to provide it
when I think somebody needs it what kept
me going was like like literally and I'm
not joking I'd rather die than not be an
entrepreneur die die so like what was I
gonna do kill myself like I'm like you
know so no way so they're like you
understand there was no option like I
didn't respect anybody else's opinion
enough to even let it be a consideration
hi Marisa Lloyd from sky-blue customer
service experts how are you I'm good
thank you
oh good I'm wearing my suit you you wore
a suit to get noticed because you
thought a lot of those other people
would have wear a suit I think you were
right yeah you're a [ __ ] gross hacker
thank you very much
[Music]
I love being you and I think it has a
big future in customer service as a
customer service platform okay because
the conversational style and you can
actually use audio and your voice and
empathy I think that'd be good for
businesses and I just wondered what your
thoughts are for the future of anger so
as you know oh all right you may know
I've been very curious about it I've
been using it I've been talking about it
I've seen a lot of you adopt it as well
I don't and this is very similar to what
I do with snapchat and other platforms I
I think voice is a very big platform I
think it's quite convenient I love how
they did it you just put up to your ear
right they've done a lot of things right
with the product I love how you onboard
but now that I've decided it's good now
I don't pay attention now I wait
so I already believe it's good but now I
need to know if you think it's good and
when I say you do I don't mean you dick
I mean I mean I mean I mean the market
the union right it's not gonna mean jack
[ __ ] to customer service if nobody's on
it yeah got it
so so I think it's good I like it now I
have to wait for it to have 25 million
users then I'll pay attention oh yeah
[Applause]
hey Gary my name is why I teach
creativity through super consciousness
and through super consciousness yeah
I'm pom for network what does that mean
no no no I actually don't know what that
is what is that basically I believe
there's a lot of unconscious activities
going around the world I believe that to
Brussels being one of the explained and
explain it well I'm consciously I
believe that we have an illusion that
we're separate and and actually that
there's [ __ ] going out there
trying to get selfish agendas resolved
when actually we all here to create and
create from a place of service in
relationship to each other so okay empty
the guru thing I do seminars I speak you
know what's up it's good to hear
someone's away as much as I do on stage
I get a lot of stick for that yeah but
my thing is I actually feel strongly
against a lot of these so-called gurus
out there in the world self our personal
development okay and I kind of get torn
between sticking to my guns sticking to
my product in my service which does
really well which is why I'm retired
customers and then taking a directive
particular on social media okay I
specifically points are gaps in you know
the [ __ ] philosophies that are that
are sorts of people okay
that don't actually get results like for
me if I sound comes to my event and they
don't get a result like I want to give
them my back okay
like whether I think they've [ __ ] up
or not doesn't matter okay and I think
there's a lot going on in the world
today where people are just rinsing
people for money because they're
believed that gurus the game hunters
good good news not just today it's
always happened keep going
and so my
yeah do I keep gunning and just doing my
products and keeping keeping quiet to
myself or do I go on like a bit of an
attack but the smile well I think I mean
you know I think that's a very personal
question I mean you know I don't know
right like I don't know like that's a
bit you know like for what because you
want to clean up the space I don't go on
an attack I love your aggressive stance
in your directness and and so I'm a
direct person but that does ruffle a few
feathers along the way yeah I don't give
a [ __ ] about anybody's feathers me too
so that's your allergic to [ __ ]
presence there yeah good I [ __ ] like
I just you know to me I think it has to
come from what really drives you right
like nobody should decide what your path
is on that yeah we should have you got
it for about three more so that we can
get everyone's book signed and we're
gonna come with three more three more
yeah and then we're gonna take we're
gonna take a three three four minute gap
and then set up the book signing so for
the next three questions make them go
back to say and also make them make them
questions make them punchy and questions
just that will you don't judge people's
questions I'm not judging them let's go
Darla's gonna get signing them
say something from a mother of children
with special needs that you've given me
permission to not send that to
university and not and not and not and
who'd have thought so I love your only
cynical script to two and a half and I
can if I want to love that thank you
and I'm not an entrepreneur I'm
self-employed
yes you know I don't hustle I've got
kids I want to be there for just do yep
I just I'm sorry
thank you so much for doing that because
it's my husband is a public school bully
you know he was well educated st. nurses
Stephen Hawking and the children why
don't you I have never been as popular
as when I have a mic but he was asking
you about and genuinely I I hate saying
no to me was can you pick the last two
people because you pick the guy with the
record because I like the way he's been
trying to hack that I'm go safe from the
goal this calm and you can follow me at
the gold discs everywhere I'm looking 53
you look good I'm it we're in the
minority
I make [ __ ] yep I make stuff yeah and I
just want to find it another way we
selling we do things like the number one
on the day you were born
thank you very much what was let me pass
that forward thank you
what was number one and we do the move
the number one on the day you were born
and we do weather first dances but we
tend to be one page yeah have you one
Facebook Ads some song yes what's going
on are you good at it I don't give a
[ __ ] that is not the right excuse that's
not the right excuse I understand about
the hell I figure that part you say you
said okay number one how timely Space
Oddity I love it
thank you so so first of all you're 53
it's your business it's Bobby's good you
it's not passion great even better great
Facebook yeah
you will kill with it do I need to do
video and just know you need to target
people that were born in 1975 with the
1975 [ __ ] you will kill with it a
company called BuzzFeed fundamentally
built them Empire on the back of that
targeting yeah I don't want to hear that
I'm not good at it cuz you're 53 yeah
like but I'll follow you and them well
you can follow [ __ ] Gandhi I don't
give a [ __ ] that's like I want you to be
good at it because it's do you know what
a layup is I don't know if you guys use
that slang
it's a [ __ ] layup it's your business
that is targeted a one-to-one basis is
insanely easy to convert on Facebook if
you gave it more than a [ __ ] ride
god bless god bless listen there's 70
there's gonna be a busy guys there's 70
million people that can [ __ ] like
it's it's a layup you have to figure it
out
if you do it your business will go
tremendously well and you'll have more
time to do your passion alright last
question of the evening I want to go
with that dude all the way in the corner
who never thought he was gonna have a
chance to ask the question are we
looking at that yeah yep you okay sorry
Jay listen to fresh mommy to sign it yes
yes all right Gary no you can't promote
you got the [ __ ] sit relax
all right my man so I run a video
marketing agency Gary very good and
we're so passionate about facebook video
ads at the minute because of that soggy
if it could be okay do you think that's
gonna be where all the attention goes in
terms of video content and spend the
money with video marking not all but a
fuckload so do you see it in terms of
taking of YouTube as any player in terms
of content as well not taking over but
taking a ton of market share so you
definitely recommend to keep focusing in
specializing in that skill clients yes
but also start building scale to make
video for native snapchat thank you big
fan you're welcome
[Applause]